find out on this episode of LED live hey
everybody welcome back to LED live we
get to expose some darkness with the
light of Christ you guys are gonna want
to hear this message because we're gonna
discuss a topic that is needed in our
world it's about sexuality okay what do
you just say what I said what'd he just
say I have no idea that's why I'm asking
you what he just said oh he said work
yes Keith give us a little preference on
what we're gonna talk about today so
today we're talking about a presentation
I named love is what and it's a mature
topic that's why we have the rating on
the screen for those parents out there
you should never just watch anything
with your kid the first time you should
always watch it before you watch with
your child good advice for sure we're
not here to do anything you know I'm
graphically explicit or anything that
but we're just talking about things that
maybe your child shouldn't be exposed to
yet and we want you to make that
decision on when you talk to them about
those things so just a warning a little
disclaimer so that you know you don't
just have your ten year old you know on
our channel whenever they want you want
to screen these programs
sorry guys my phone was buzzing the
reality of the situation is the world is
pumping misinformation about sexuality
to the kids so they're getting mixed
messages already and trust me by age ten
years old probably a lot of them have
been exposed more than you you wish they
were so we need to like discuss this
kind of topic we need to know how do we
begin to approach this how do we begin
to protect ourselves against it so
that's why we really wanted to do this
type of show so I'm excited to hear what
you have to say yeah all right well
let's get into it we're gonna look at
this topic of sexuality through the lens
of the Bible and today we're gonna look
at a number of statistics and you know
just reports from different watchdog
groups out there I don't want to start
with those verse from the Bible
it's from Ecclesiastes 2:10 and it says
whatever my eye is desired it did that I
did not keep from them I did not
withhold my heart from any pleasure for
my heart rejoiced in all my labor and
this was my reward from all my labor
I find this verse is very descriptive of
our society today you know we generally
do not hesitate to withhold you know
anything before our eyes it's a society
or it's just like pretty much anything
goes and discretion is going out the
window and so we need to take some time
like Solomon did and reflect and say
what am I putting before my eyes and
what impact is that having upon my life
Bill Gates made an interesting statement
a few years ago he said content is king
and you know we probably agree with that
being in the media industry ourselves
but when he said content is king he said
this in a context of the media industry
and so he added to this he said content
is where I expected much of the real
money to be made on the internet just as
it was in broadcasting and we see that
trend happening today you know a lot of
the money today is being made on the
Internet you have people that are making
millions of dollars on YouTube yeah
is amazing and you know you're shopping
from home yes
and and some of these people they don't
they don't even do anything worthwhile
right I'm gonna open this box and yeah
what I got but reflecting on his
statement if content is king we should
be concerned about the content because
the content then will have influence
let's talk about the content 72% of
teens think that watching TV with a lot
of sexual content influences their peers
behavior somewhat or a lot that's pretty
teen saying this that's pretty shocking
I'm surprised most of them say I don't
affect me I do this because I want to or
whatever now these these are teens of my
generation this was published I think in
2001 hmm so this is a little bit after I
would have graduated from high school
and so that's that's you know the
context I know I'm giving my age away
hmm that's the context of when this was
written in and this comes from a medical
journal and I don't think anything has
changed in fact I would say since that
time if anything it's probably getting
worse
oh yeah you look at studies I don't know
if you're gonna show this but you look
at studies from even 10-15 years ago and
the frequency that that they were
exposed to sexual content or even just
you know imagery has just gone through
the roof yeah and we are gonna look at
some of that there's one that Common
Sense Media reported they said between
1998 and 2005 the number of sexual
scenes on TV nearly doubled well yeah
it's not 1998 anymore in fact we've
already passed 2018 this is a little bit
old but you could see that even back
then the pace is picking up right
those are my high school days man what'd
he say yeah I know me too you all right
here's another one from another Medical
Journal said adolescents use the media's
sources of information about sex drugs
aids and violence as well as help to
learn how to behave in relationships you
know I've been to a lot of youth
speaking places where they have a lot of
different speakers talking about
different topics and they have like
breakout rooms and there's always a
relationship component when it comes to
like big youth groups
and and stuff and they are the most
attended I mean you should see the line
out the door of kids trying to get in
and listen to what topic you know the
Bible has to say about relationships and
stuff so this is not a shocker it's the
biggest decision you're gonna make one
of the biggest recent decisions you're
gonna make in your life your life
partner and not even just life partner
throughout your whole life it's all
about relationships how you connect with
people how you communicate with people
so it would make sense that's
well-attended yeah so then if if this is
such a big influencer on your behavior
and obviously what you're watching this
becomes extremely important all right
it's for all the naysayers out there
that yeah yeah what our watch doesn't
affect me it's just entertainment I know
what happened though like the difference
between the 2001 teens vs. nowadays
because 72 percent believe that they
were being affected nowadays it's like
oh I'm not being affected so well I mean
I think if you just observe like pop
culture entertainment the sexual like
content has has doubled right but you
think about the access that kids have to
porn and other things nowadays I mean
it's just through the roof so I would
say that this generation is probably
overly sexually charged more than even
previous generation do you think they're
saying they're not being affected
because it's so normal no it is it's
it's like how can it affect it if it's
normal whereas before it wasn't normal
so you can see the effect because
society is actually shifting every
generation says it doesn't affect me you
know everybody wants to believe it
doesn't affect him everybody wants to
believe they're above you know something
having an effect on them right look at
the 60s man everybody was like it's okay
right now you've got a fallout of
problems from the 60s and even now this
generation will look back on that and
say wow they messed some stuff up back
there and we are paying the price for it
so
you know it may take years for the next
next generation to see the problems that
we have now but I think everything
affects us so primetime TV this was 30
years ago okay
30 years ago we said there were a
hundred and forty-three incidents of
sexual behavior on network television
and it's a surprising source Planned
Parenthood put that statistic out so
this is in one year's time there was 143
incidents of sexual behavior yeah during
the 1987 to 1988 so on a normal airway
of television like not yeah Network th
yeah
network TV so I'm showing all these
statistics from yesteryear just so that
when we move forward we'll see you know
where are things at now I say media is
education you know and being an
educational tool what are we learning
obviously teams relate media as an
educational tool because they say well
this is where I go to learn about
violence this is where I go to learn
about sex AIDS drugs whatever so we know
it's an educational tool I'm sure
there's a youtube video how to do
everything
exhausting right so not that long ago
less than a year ago 2018 there was a
group called the Parents Television
Council and they published a study about
media and specifically on family
comedies and they wanted to see what
kind of sexual content are kids being
exposed to you through that
haven't you now family comedies you
would think that's supposed to be
family-friendly that should be safe for
pretty much anybody I mean we have
ratings on television right and those
ratings you know allow us to see what's
what's in the different programs and so
let's see as we go through this what
they found out 80% of all primetime
broadcast network family comedies
analyzed in this study contained
instances of adults using explicit
sexual dialogue in front of children
well and child viewers of supposin
family comedies are routinely exposed to
dialogue and scenarios such as
[Music]
now I remember when I was a kid do you
guys remember a television show called
Three's Company
Ya Ya Ya Ya nope I don't know what
you're gonna say but I recently watched
that thinking oh this might be clean
it's kind of back in the day there was
so many sexual references and all kinds
of like terrible things and I put it in
that and I remember that was sold to
people as a family-friendly show so you
know even when we were kids they were
sliding on yes I often kind of talk
about this trait this change over time
because I grew up on shows like full
house Family Matters
I mean Family Matters Steve Urkel
accepted Christ in a church like you
would never see that today and you know
like on full house maybe the girl gets
caught drinking a beer and they have a
family intervention she's crying I'll
never do it again that ruined my life
one beer you know now the mother is
selling weed to the kids at the high
school and like they're having skittles
parties yeah and I mean it even
progressed to like married with children
where the dads just sitting there
drinking a beer and hey you know it
doesn't like his wife and and it and I
actually could see the world around me
just transform with that I mean my own
household we actually used to have some
standards about we're not gonna watch
that or do this and as we laxed on those
things a beer with dinner is normal or
whatever you know it just what you see
is becomes the norm interesting these
are the shows that they analyzed from
several different networks ABC CBS FOX
NBC and CW and you can see there's a
number of shows on here wide variety
some of them apparently organized more
than others but like The Simpsons for
example the Family Guy and and there's a
number on it you know rosanne different
shows so what did they find out about
all these different shows well I said
this the discussions of sex have been
scientifically proven to influence teens
in their own sexual behavior at a time
when Hollywood is increasingly conscious
of the harm done by crude sexually
harassing language used in front of
women and is taking steps to read
user eliminated it is tragic that the
entertainment industry remains oblivious
to the effect of sexualizing talk in
front of children both child actors and
child viewers at home and then they said
numerous researchers have reported
strong correlations between viewing sex
on TV and subsequent attitudes beliefs
and behaviors with television serving as
a kind of sexual super peer for early
maturing teens I mean you think about
the influence that you know teens are
paying attention to how everyone else is
dressing how everyone else is being and
now you've got this like super
concentrated super exciting you know
television the way that it plays out is
they take away all of the boring moments
I mean life does not happen like that
and so they're showing you only these
exciting parts of the stories which is
how you mean that sensory with young
people and they're sitting there like
soaking this out I mean for sure this is
this has to have an effect on them I
like the little graphic that they used
at the end to kind of in their report
and they said because our children are
watching you know there's all kinds of
kids watching and I feel bad for all
these children that you know they have
all this unrestricted access and the
things that they can stumble on to
completely innocently you have to be
careful what you type directly into a
web browser you know I remember when I
was 14 at school I made the mistake of
typing a direct address into a web
browser thinking I am going to do a
report on the White House I thought
dot-com you just type what I didn't
understand Danka of dotnet all those at
that time I was 14 I mean we just had
computers at school and I did not get
the White House you know I got something
else and I was like quickly shouting my
computer and I'm like I'm not supposed
to be seeing this you know but it's so
easy to access that kind of content and
even more so now you know you just typed
the wrong word into a search engine and
up can pop all manner of pictures and
video so I thought this was interesting
doing this research
I found that 10 very adult films were
rated G by Netflix g27 not even PG rated
G yes now I can't say that that's the
case now it could be that Netflix has
completely changed since as information
has come out but at that time just a
short time ago within the last couple of
years you could find all of this content
rated G on Netflix so you can see
there's some very explicit terms on the
screen ok the word in the title
shouldn't even be on oh geez Ackley what
we movie has the word porn so wait a
minute after porn ends is a g-rated
Netflix show as of 2017 it was I don't
know if it still is but at one time you
could get access to these g-rated okay
to have a different rating yeah yeah
just the title alone my question would
be has Netflix always been a family
streaming service and what I mean by
that is they've just added on a whole
bunch of categories and children is one
of them with all the cartoons and stuff
was that always there do they begin like
that that they changed us because they
added a children's section a family
section I can't say I know all the
answers to that I'm not very Netflix a V
okay I have a [__] out true but I don't
use it very much you know I'll go on
there every once in a while to look
something up but you know so I don't
know and I don't know if you click on
this I know when I log in I have the
children's box but I've never clicked on
that because I have no need to for
myself and I don't just let my children
have free access to Netflix so for me
it's never been relevant that question
of my own life you know but I don't know
maybe maybe somebody who knows how
Network Netflix works can comment below
you know I have no idea it's startling
nonetheless to think that you could just
get access to this as a g-rated yeah I
wouldn't want to content this screen on
my TV when in public when like a
neighbor comes in be like what are you
watching they're just g-rated movie
a list yeah so what about contributions
from longer standing shows that have
made their mark on pop culture right
like The Simpsons I mean this show is
terrible Simpsons has as datoria Slee
had a lot of content that you don't want
your kids exposed to everything from
secret societies to totally bashing God
to I mean all sorts of sexual innuendos
I'm gonna go through a number of them
here you know you can feel free to
comment their question oh all of these
shows are labeled family-friendly shows
I wouldn't say that they are but you
know that the Simpsons was on that list
that the Parents Television Council went
through that our family comedies this
one necessarily wouldn't be considered a
family comedy but still you know it's
it's out there it's freely accessible
unless you're using I guess a V chip on
your television or you know being very
careful you know your kid can just
access this you know what I think is
interesting is ben shapiro actually
interviewed one of the writers for this
show Desperate Housewives one of the
things I'm proudest about is the
addition of the neighbors the gay
neighbors on Wisteria Lane because
they're there they're a part of the
neighborhood no one seems to notice it
and I think that just having gay
neighbors be a part of the street and I
don't really talk about their sexuality
much to me that became its own political
statement which is see you can have gay
neighbors and they can be perfectly fine
and fit in with with you know the rest
of the folks and it doesn't change
anything and you know you kind of hope
that you're preparing the way planning
little seeds in the minds of people who
sometime over the next few years are
going to have gay neighbors buy a house
on their street and for me that that's
that's the most effective political
message is that it's not particularly
aggressive it's just there and it's it's
slowly changing a perception that like
there was that much purposeful thought
going into it and that kind of thing
actually has an influence you know show
you know but it's with the show but
people watch it and they go they go this
is normal
so if they show really non normal things
you know like the you know dad's got
three wives and this and that I mean
that then seals into the population that
is normal yeah I ran across a quote
recently from Psychology Today you know
the PhD in psychology said you know it's
it's really amazing that people think
that with television we have these
commercials you know that we believe
affect people I mean we sell advertising
why do we still advertising because it
works or anything you know it affects
people but we believe that the hour-long
programming sandwich in between the
commercials has no effect on people yeah
I mean it doesn't make sense it's
inconsistent logic right yeah that's a
very good point cuz yes so short and it
affects you so powerfully yeah did they
invest millions of dollars yeah per
second time and just like how
commercials work it's through
familiarity with that product when you
see that brand over and over and over
and over and over again when you go to
the store we all gravitate to things
that are familiar to us so if you watch
a lot of Miss portrayals of what the
family unit looks like miss portrayals
of sexuality that becomes normal to you
and you begin to think that that's just
okay so then when you get in a situation
where you have what is normal or
biblically you're right doesn't even
seem exciting anymore I was gonna be
like what I was seeing on TV a night
right yeah so we wind up with shows like
Modern Family which is nothing like
Leave It to Beaver alright alright and
and isn't this a picture of society if
what our families really are like today
so they say life imitates art or is it
that art is imitating life I mean I
think both are playing off each other
yeah definitely Game of Thrones if
you've heard of the show mekin unless
you're living under a rock you've
probably heard of Game of Thrones you
know I was looking at an article and I
can't remember who it was by it was an
unusual source I should say was a source
I didn't expect it from they had an
article about all the whole gamut of
game Game of Thrones relationships and
there was everything
every was everything there's incest the
actual first episode of Game of Thrones
started out with a rape scene and it's
like there's rape there's incest there's
cheating there's kill I mean it's like
homosexuality there's every kind of this
is probably like the most-watched show
right now right right well I'm not maybe
no more because that you're ended but
yeah I mean it was definitely one of the
most-watched ever so you think about
that the most-watched show is probably
the worst show up to date of course
there's you know ones that are a little
more blatant yeah they're not hiding it
right and then there's this you've
probably heard of this Fifty Shades of
Grey made a lot of headlines for its
content
and then you know recently we did a
program on Hollywood in politics right
and how you know the unplanned movie was
basically censored in some ways you know
so it's amazing how certain things are
censored and certain things are pushed
to radar yeah
certain things are rated-r but most of
these the content that's in them yeah
you know it's really awkward is being on
an airplane and somebody's watching like
Game of Thrones and there's like a sex
scene and it's like you know you're
always just kind of like oh my goodness
there's like tons of people around this
is super awkward but if I've seen this
thing on tons of planes and people like
have no problem watching those kind of
scenes with all sorts of people around
so you know that should give you a
telltale sign of you know where society
is at for sure so even shows that we
might agree show love in a positive
context there are still significant
problems and relevant magazine did or
they did an article and they summed it
up this way
they said talking about the depiction of
love concentrated love in a short amount
of time without all the dailies so in
other words when you're whenever you're
watching all this programming on TV
you're only seeing these very
concentrated moments in time you don't
see all the day-to-day you know yeah I
mean you're it's not like okay these two
people are in love and they're
doing the dishes together and you know
they're going on a walk and you know the
guys helping fold the laundry you don't
see any in that step all you see is the
concentrated portions that they want you
to see you know the ones that are overly
sexualized yeah that's a real thing I
was listening to Family Radio and there
was a episode of this doctor I forget
his name but he was making the
connection interesting to Disney
characters and Disney Princesses
Princesses and how that's messing with
the minds of little girls because they
grow up and then they have this
perception of what they want in a
relationship what they want love to be
and then it doesn't work out because
that's not realistic
and then either they end up settling
which is bad which is worse because if
they get something that they should not
stand for it to begin with boy they just
said you know I'm done with this and
they actually don't give love a shot at
all just being alone it's like what he's
not rich he doesn't have like muscles
I've actually heard a lot of like radio
programs the stuff about marriage and
that's the way it was like the woman
months into the marriage is like this is
not what I thought it was gonna be you
know and in an in reality there's
nothing wrong with the marriage it's a
normal marriage but they just had these
super high expectations that it didn't
meet and they think well the problem is
him so I'm gonna move on to the next guy
won't guess what months into that
marriage the same thing I mean the
marriage is all about sacrifice and
sticking with it and working through it
and communication what's up with that
you know why are the girls itself with
the guys what's happening guys we're
simple man you can keep us happy most of
the thing no surprise they also said
that the programs were highly sexualized
they also said what you're seeing is the
beginning of the relationship at the end
of the program hmm right so things are
just now getting started by the time
this is all developed you're not seeing
the rest of it right I mean like the
wedding is just before the credits roll
and stuff yeah and you know or they're
they're just getting together by the end
of maybe they finally realize they love
each other and
and it's supposed to be happily ever
after after that I mean that's that's
how marriage is though you know there's
this honeymoon stage where you know all
you see is red I mean I can remember
marrying my wife and thinking this woman
cannot do anything wrong
she is literally perfect and then one
year rolled around and I was like first
I've got in my life I'm sure she was
thinking the same thing but the love
takes a different form I think it's the
same as our relationship with God as
well you know we have this really fast
passionate beginning with you gone right
everything is just like gold boom boom
boom everything's blowing up and you're
starting to see all these things and
you're really super passionate about God
and then the daily sets in and the
relationship takes a different form and
you need that kind of like you know
daily maintenance just like in a real
relationship you need that daily
maintenance date night yeah yeah you
know which segues really well into their
next point when all the fancy stuff
fades am I still in love right yeah you
find yourself asking asking yourself
yeah am I really in love I don't I don't
think in my marriage I had so much of
that we had a probably slightly
different experience and yet similar in
many ways to other people people used to
tell us you know it gets hard about 10
years mm-hmm
when you have kids and for us it was
about that you know about 10 years I
know for me specifically I have oh I was
having a hard time it's like supposed to
pay attention to me anymore what's going
on you know I know but I think I'm not
gonna say I didn't have high
expectations but I don't think I had any
grandiose expectations and I goes
probably more a little more grounded and
you know what marriage was gonna be like
it was for me I probably I don't not
that I didn't have great expectations
for my wife but I it was probably better
for me at the beginning you know then
then what I was projected I think is no
everything I've heard that's normal
yeah well for each of you where do you
think you got your expectations from
likely media
yeah totally princess tour
my wife says I never cry well like you
were saying why is it why is it girls
you know girls are always looking for
this thing like romance and all this
guys we don't really look at that but I
think the media does play on that a lot
a woman she's trying to look as
attractive as she can to get the guy
that's got the money and and that's
what's the media pushes so you got the
guy trying to make all the money by
working and but then when you get a
marriage then it's like you work too
much well I'm trying to get the money to
make you happy and have this trophy wife
so it's really a bad combination
yeah and at the end of the day they
called it emotional pornography sure
that was a really interesting lever hmm
very clever I don't know if I'm skipping
ahead here but where should we get our
influences from was that movie laying
around
well let's talk about it where should we
get our influences from I mean you're
bringing the question let's tackle it
where have your influences come from I
would have to say media as well and
where should they come from right
awesome anchors who was well though
oddly enough okay the conversation that
I had in school and even people's
response people's reactions to certain
situations so a student would come and
say man this happened in my household
and there's a reaction in my pear group
who's like huh well that's interesting
like maybe maybe this is how we should
act in this situation but then what's
influencing your peers that would assume
they're their parents see that's why
it's kind of difficult for me I know the
the it should come from your parents and
how they interact with each other and
things like that but coming from a
single-parent household that was quite
interesting for me to figure out so I'm
assuming that those kids would come and
we would discuss in school would get it
from their households but overall we
were all pretty much getting a big chunk
from the movies were to watch and the TV
shows so I I know we've had this
conversation before would you say church
had a big influence on you over
relationships like seeing relationships
from your church members or you know
interacting with friends as parents or
anything as
I think that the model comes from the
home but not always it's realistic that
you have that model in the home such as
your case and I think that you know the
media probably plays a big influence
into what your ideas play out or what
you what you understand this is a proper
context of a relationship and even in
many homes they get a wrong picture of
it in in those homes you know I come
from a broken home
my parents divorced when I was little
and you know so I didn't have quite a
clear picture of it as well from my
family Union right and I would say
probably my ideas were largely shaped
from from movies right I don't know just
to see it doesn't mean you understand it
so I would see certain things in church
but and as it wasn't something I would
really dwell on it usually in the
conclusion was oh well that's not my
reality that's not what I have so
whatever you know just move on it looked
nice but I I didn't delve into it and to
the fact or to the extent where I would
go ask questions or I would really
understand what was happening between
the parents I think what helped shape my
understanding of especially an emotional
relationship between a man and woman or
how a man should treat a woman was
actually in pathfinders we would have
chivalry classes and and just general
discussions where an adult was involved
in the discussion it wasn't just pairs
talking amongst themselves that was a
setting where I was able to ask
questions and listen to adult responses
I think that's important and not just a
kid looking all the time because then a
kid can draw their own conclusions and
maybe even just block it out completely
and that doesn't help right yeah so
that's why I hesitated answering your
your question about change yeah I often
try to picture a world that maybe in the
50s
an EMP going off or something and
there's no it affected just media
there's somehow like where would we be
right now if there was no media to
influence the world like how would
people dress how they talk
you know you would be influenced by the
people that you observe around exactly
like community and like you said like
that's crazy like there's a class about
chivalry imagine if you went to school
and there is a Christian counselor
teaching you about this is what a
marriage should look like instead of
real sex can be done like this and
here's some condoms and I know you're
only five but we're gonna teach you this
crazy thing you know like now I don't
want to totally beat up media because
what if the media was portraying a
proper context of television I mean what
would that do to the family units in
society because there's a lot of
families that they spend dinner eating
watching television and those sitcoms
that are around that that primetime hour
and you know I wouldn't beat up media is
so bad if they were proper portrayals of
it but the fact that it's most often
this miss portrayal broken down I think
like why watching crazy we literally
become crazy that make sense this
thing's real controlled and even like
the school system the reason we don't
have these shivery classes in public
school well they're not Christian
schools you know they're teaching you
evolution or BIGBANG and I mean there's
their godless schools I guess if we were
to be specific we should say mainstream
media doesn't have a right portrayal cuz
they're really just looking for the
money
it's excellence so that's what's gonna
be in front of your face if you just did
a little bit of research I'm sure
there's plenty of right good resources
that's why your family it matters what
you watch be careful with what you watch
it's not necessarily that you're just
watching something it's just make
positive choices for that right I would
agree with you I think all the craziness
that we've been talking about ends us up
at a point where we have him if he's
like divorced party says kiss this
marriage goodbye where the guy he has a
party to celebrate his divorce is as
white as his ex-wife at the party are
they both celebrating here I don't think
they're both celebrate okay I didn't get
that from that cuz I have seen stuff
like that
and I've seen people and they're the
couple is smiling as they have their
divorce paper and that goes on you
Instagram and stuff and it's like
they're celebrating it yeah but the fact
that people are even okay with this it's
just it's sad you know you know there's
a broken marriage is nothing to
celebrate at all it's it's and and the
real losers of these situations
especially there's kids involved is the
kids yeah you know definitely always all
right so let's take some time to talk a
little bit about music all right
touchy touchy yeah do you think music
has had an effect on society over time
we want to take a look at that here is a
report from say joven says themes of
lust and love and popular music lyrics
from 1971 to 2011 so we've got a pretty
good span there you know to take a look
at so let's see what we found out in 40
years what do you notice about this
graph you have lust with the solid
diamonds and you have love with the
dotted squares what's happening loves
coming down lusts going up that these
are the themes that are changing over
time and when did they start to really
kind of change and switch positions
sometime between 2001 well it looks like
after 2006 yeah
it's about 2007 8 we really started to
see that flip just switch now in the
same report they analyzed what about if
we factor in the songs which take both
into account because there are songs
that talk about lust and love together
and then there's songs that are just
predominantly lost and songs that are
predominantly love then what happens to
our our chart and you can see here that
still the ones that are lust only are
more predominant than the other two
themes well together so lust is on the
rise as a theme and music and just to
define the difference between lust and
love it's like the two polar opposite
ends of the spectrum love is very giving
right
what can I
give you what I mean forgot so loved the
world he gave His only begotten Son
right
lust is taking I mean Fifty Shades of
Grey I'm gonna take it from you and I'm
gonna tie you up you know it's like it's
it's a very opposite end of the spectrum
but yet it's sold to you in this in this
quasi you know this is love under the
garb of love and it's not love it's it's
it's actually something totally opposite
it's what can I get out of it it's
selfish love is really what it is
should one go without the other I think
we should have a pure form of love in
our relationship yeah well if both
people love then you don't have to worry
about what you can get because that
person wants the gift to you that's
right yeah so here's another report
psychology of music what has America
been seen about trends in themes in the
u.s. top 40 songs from 1960 to 2010 so
this one is a 50-year span study what do
we discover from this here we can see a
chart with lots of data on it hone in on
the top two rows here you have
relationships and love from the 60s
forward at the end but more important is
that change then look at sex versus
sexual desire below that started out
about 18% and went to 41.7%
so huge change more than doubled
whereas relationships and love has been
on maybe a slow steady decline but not
by much in fact you know it maybe isn't
statistically enough to say that it's
really changed all that much the
definitely sex and sexual desire has
been climbing and as I look at this you
know it's it's been climbing along with
like wealth and status dance and dancing
but definitely the most probably the
most dramatic change I would say is in
sex and sexual desire music over the
last it looks like there's like a
pendulum effect in this every 10 years
it's kind of like not so higher than
really
and then back down like liquor religion
the sixties nobody's talking about God
70s you're talking my god again the
eighties mmm not really
90s aiya 90s was my childhood and I feel
like there was a lot of God influenced
stuff so even more than that consistent
to what's relevant because look at race
and ethnicity in the 60s point five to
the two thousand eleven point seven yeah
but then you take a look at something
like death death is pretty much always
relevant and it has a much bigger jump
into the 90s and then goes down in the
2000s what's driving this called your
society like the collective the Allu
mindset of the people but it's
definitely a reflection of what we're
about is what we sing about that's what
we're about so what we're into what we
believe it's what we like
it's what's affecting us you know music
is often a reflection of what's in our
hearts I mean it's it's what's coming
out so my takeaway from that is over the
past 40 50 years sexual themes have not
increased and that there has been a
significant increase in the proportion
of songs with the themes of lust with
the absence of love and romantic
feelings sexuality has remained pretty
much constant across the board but while
it's remained constant you have a much
higher proportion of songs with lust and
sexual desire and those kinds of things
over love you know we're still singing
about you know love but if the context
of that love has changed what it means
to us has changed over time I think it's
very dangerous if this is all someone
has to go off of if this is their main
influence if you can go back to the to
the statistics because the main thing
talked about is lust not the effects of
it what happens after it you know when
two people unite and in love man and a
woman or what's usually what comes next
is the development of a family but you
have love and relationships all the way
up here being talked about and look
families all the way down here
about what about you know violence that
comes out of lust and I want I will take
not thinking of how will it affect the
other person violence can break out you
know all these different things
understanding your personal identity
before even looking for love and really
relationships there's you know let's
focus on this and not all this other
stuff and this is this other stuff is
real life and I feel like good times and
partying on their eyes I wonder how they
kind of judged what was love or lust
because you have songs where they're
like I saw you at the club I fell right
in love or something like I knew right
then that moment we fell in love and
that night we went home no yeah no
studies like this will have specific
criteria that they define beforehand you
know to determine that we also learned
that themes of lust in the absence of
love were especially prevalent in
hip-hop and rap music as a particular
genre like well above other genres so
this is what the reports are these
shifts in themes found in popular music
may both influence cultural norms and
ships this is their conclusion I think
you know if we think about that it's
really kind of self evident you know we
get the media affects us and if people
can deny that we talked about that you
know it doesn't affect me but we look at
what's you know things that are
prevalent in our lives like media we can
see the change happening we can see the
effect happening over time so it's very
hard I think to deny that this has no
effect on us at all and they also said
that there has been acceptance of
sexuality outside of love relationships
and that's how we wind up with music
videos like des Pacita it's in Spanish
so unless you know Spanish really well
or you translate the lyrics what is that
thing about if you watch it visually
have you have any of you seen is that
the one most to use ever yeah this is
the number one youtube video of all time
I think it broke that record in seven
months
yeah because of it overly sexualized
content I guarantee you if you took the
woman out of the of the music video he
would not be a top music
i I I don't think I could in good
conscience read the translated lyrics on
the show it's it's pretty explicit so
what is des Osito in Spanish I'm
desperate I don't know what slow slow
hmm I mean slow means slow okay it's
very ambiguous and then you have songs
like shape of you by a journey in this
it's describes a relationship that
begins you know and then it quickly
leads to the bedroom that's pretty much
the song before long the two people are
dating the woman's body and the man's
impetuosity bring them together and then
you have songs like sugar by Maroon five
that are also in the same vein with very
suggestive lyrics and also artwork and
so I think what we've seen is a very you
know cause-and-effect relationship here
this is from the journal Pediatrics the
title at the article a sexuality
contraception and the media the Council
on Communications and Media said
virtually every rated R rated TV movie
or teen movie since the 1980s has
contained at least one nude scene and
often several instances of sexual
intercourse for example American Pie
movie series human what's that like they
came right to my mind the American Pie
like we saw the interview of like
thirteen-year-old kids or like the
lesbian scene you know whatever and then
they continued by saying teen movies
also contain distorted views of romance
and normal adolescent sexuality so
probably the most prominent pediatric
journal that there is the journal
pediatrics and medicine this is what
they're saying man bunch of doctors
they're like look this is what's
happening this is what you need to take
note of as parents if we have a bunch of
PhD professionals you know MD is
noticing this in our society we can
probably tell all day long oh it doesn't
affect me your doctor thinks it does
they also said teen magazines are
popular with pre Allyson and adolescent
girls and devote an average of two and a
half pages
per issue into sexual topics coverage of
sex as a health issue in magazines is
more common than on TV but the
overarching focus seems to be on
deciding when to lose one's virginity if
your daughter is interested in those
teen magazines buyer beware right
because they're probably not gonna be
lining up with your Christian believes
almost guaranteed it's not just in music
it's in magazines as well what was it in
the teen magazine that you guys are
bringing up the other day
oh it seen Vogue Teen Vogue well was it
sex work is real work yep
an article in Teen Vogue that was
talking about the sexual like like as in
prostitution they were saying that
what's the difference between a
physician the doctor talking about sex
and getting paid for that or discussing
sex or counseling on sex and getting
paid for that what's the difference
between that person and a sex worker a
big difference why I'm a big difference
honey I'm going to the doctor wink
to a doctor to learn about something to
do with sexuality or some issue if
you're working it out on the street I
mean that's like two totally different
ball fields oh wow they might just want
to just merge they just combine the jobs
the logic that we have totally lost our
discernment in most areas so yeah check
out our Facebook page you can find the
article on there and while you're there
go ahead and follow us all right thank
you for that plug also here's another
plug check out sue dolla G because it
talks about how the media affects your
brain and how many psychologists doctors
and neuro scientists is it gonna take to
make us believe that that's that Vick
Thomas you know you should look in the
description below for a link to see Tala
ji also it was reported the Internet has
become an abundant source of both sexual
information and pornography that cannot
be regulated online pornography is now a
1 billion dollar a year industry in a
national sample of 1510 the 17-year olds
10 10 to 17 nearly half the Internet
users had been exposed to online
pornography in the previous year
in addition unwanted sexual
solicitations and harassment are not
uncommon although they may not be as
frequent as parents fear so can you
imagine half of 10 year olds being
exposed to pornography I mean I have a
son who's 12 I have a son who's 9 I mean
you're such talking right it right at
those ages it's like the kids they're
they're happy to build paper airplanes
you know and that tool of the devil just
gets a hold of him I think I was 10
years old the first time that I was
exposed to a porno magazine mm-hmm 10
years old around the same age probably
younger yeah but you know we're talking
about media that you can kind of control
like you cannot have a TV in your home
or not have music in your house but I
mean if you're a normal person that's
together grocery store like literally
every Cosmo grow magazine is always at
this eye level for a kid and it's like a
chick barely covering her nipples with a
jacket or something really you look the
first word your eye sees is six
yep so I mean you can't just you're
exposed to it everywhere here is an
article that I found it said Nicole
crassus found that both men and women's
magazine kits contain a single vision of
female sexuality that women should
primarily concern themselves with
attracting and sexually satisfying men
so sure
Nicole crafts is found both men and
women's magazines contain a single
vision of female sexuality that women
should primarily concern themselves with
attracting and sexually satisfying me
that's infuriating as it should be you
know it's interesting this is affecting
women in so many ways
I was watching the video documentary
from the Heritage Foundation they're
saying of course this is not speaking
for all of them but some transgender
people their roots are are from trying
wool let's see some
trans men okay sorry let's confuse a
woman who are transitioning and to be
men okay
the roots of that is to get away from
being sexualized to get away from the
stigma that's associated with with being
a woman and how he should act or feel or
be as a woman so this is this is insane
it's affecting people in a lot of
different ways societal pressures that's
taken serious measures to get away from
the cultural norm or whatever a really
good friend of ours of our ministry that
she was abused early on by her father
and her brother and she went headstrong
into the lesbian world and one of the
reasons that she did that was literally
to become a man to show what a man
should and how a man should treat a
woman it was really interesting
gravitated her towards more of the sort
of witch yeah version of the lesbian so
it seems to me to experience extremes
either they transform or try to
transform themselves into what they
think a man should be or they just go
ahead and allow themselves to be slapped
around and whatever by men mm-hmm Wow
yeah
so as magazines like this you know Teen
Vogue and seventeen we talked about this
these are the ones that are really one
society one sided and have that kind of
viewpoint but the one thing I want to
bring out about this is that the sources
that they typically quote our Planned
Parenthood sources when it comes to
sexual health Wow okay you're not gonna
find a wide variety there it's it's
pretty much solely from Planned
Parenthood and they're not paying the
full picture of consequence for example
from having a sexual relationship with
multiple people it's just you know it's
the Planned Parenthood Waco that keeps
them in business they can give abortions
right right yeah I just want to point
something out real quick to actually
when I lived in Los Angeles and I live
right at the beach for a little time
they were doing a cosmopolitan shoot on
the beach for the cover of Cosmopolitan
and my maybre was actually one of the
people that was working in and
facilitating it so
I went out to go watch the shoot really
interesting because to me the model was
not very attractive and I sat and kind
of watched the whole process they took
photos over they brought the photos back
they worked him in Photoshop and the end
result was absolutely stunning I mean
they made her skinnier they made her her
cheekbones right oh yeah right
everything and it was just like wow so
you don't know how much these magazines
are even doctored up there so doctored
that that in reality a lot of the times
people don't look like that
here's another Journal I found said the
pressure put on women through ads
television film and new media to be
sexually attractive and sexually active
is profound well this is nothing new
research has found that women's
representation in popular media has
steadily become more and more sexualized
over the last 40 years and given
everything that we've just seen this is
kind of like a whoa yeah that makes
sense right Noda I find interesting
interesting why is the the light only
being shown on the women I mean who are
the women having sex with the Horde
pushing the women to have sex it's it
the the larger population is men so this
is going both ways as if the male has
nothing to do with any of this
maybe he wrote the script and directed
it and mm-hmm all right here's another
article it said that television movies
music and magazines contain a great deal
of sexual content and little discussion
of emotions responsibilities or risks
associated with sexual activity for
example sexually transmitted infections
birth control and condom use so you know
you're only whenever you're watching
these things you're really only getting
one side of the story right
I remember some people told us when my
wife and I first got married they were
like look you're getting married like
don't get married unless you're ready to
have children right because
gonna happen it okay right and sure
enough about three months into our
marriage my wife comes to me she says
we're pregnant you know and so ready or
not it was here it comes but these these
magazines these TVs they you don't they
only paint the quote-unquote and
glamorous side right the lustful side of
all these situations they're not
necessarily showing you the nitty gritty
the day-to-day I mean then what happens
I mean you get pregnant and then what
are they showing you okay now this is
how you take care of a child yeah what
do you think of first gonna do though
there are shows that like teen teen
pregnancies or you know children being
born out of wedlock there are shows
surrounding that so what do you think
about those I think it's great if they
show a responsible you know something
like that happens you know now it's time
to you know take responsibility and care
for that child if it's literally a show
that's like well you know you got
pregnant because you went to a party and
but guess what you can get rid of it now
up to nine months now I have a problem
with that kind of a show so I think that
as long as there is a clear message of
be responsible I mean this is this is
the part of life this is how life
continues and so just to be able to try
and go and have all that fun without the
responsibility there's a problem with
that yeah so in the first half of this
presentation we have looked at a lot of
statistics on music and things like that
where trends have been going in society
we've looked at what's been happening on
network television and those kinds of
things and and magazine but in the
second part of this we are going to take
a journey and look at what is happening
in society morally what is happening in
society with social media and even
pornography what direction is are we
headed what is statistics tell us and
are we changing and if we're changing
why are we changing so that is part two
so I hope you guys can check it out with
us and stay tuned for next week don't
forget to hit that
subscribe button click the little
notification bell and don't forget to
click on part two because you're going
to want to hear the conclusion of all of
this and it just gets crazier from here
but the proof is in the pudding and the
statistics tell us exactly where we're
headed
don't forget to hit the thumbs up it's a
simple easy way to help us out and share
with your friends that's right guys guys
[Music]